[Music]
in spoken up news why you're just
drawing up this ones remember submitted
by hi from Utah herring roe as they say
in Utah about 95 percent of 20,000 drug
convictions in Massachusetts have been
dismissed because of a single lab
chemist 135 yeah he bought that
incompetent lab worker in the world
Hawking math on that 95 percent of
20,000 is like 18 is like I think the
matter 905 they [ __ ] up 19,000 cases
oh damn what happened I got to know what
happens know what's your lucky day
nobody guessed oh okay times twenty nine
five it's nineteen thousand good mental
math yeah I'm gonna guess this happened
in our country kill us today alright I
want to guess in the good ol US of A
this guy was given a slap on the wrist
and told please don't ever do that again
and I can get that's a good thing he
ruined 19,000 lives no no he didn't ruin
99 he got 19,000 people out of jail
Oh oh that's okay that's what it sounds
like this story is about this woman
named Annie Duke N and for your honor he
to grow walk in a [ __ ]
usually girls are careful I know what
happened here she must have been on a
period she's about to tell a real girl
well okay so she worked at the
Department of Public Health from 2003 to
2012 and she worked on over 24,000
criminal cases and just a little
background info on her she's turned a
dad born immigrant she's described as a
soft-spoken private work obsessed
go-getter and she was always anxious to
please what's her horoscope
don't know that'll tell me everything he
can judge her anymore you know I know
the facts
she's like I know her yeah so at work
she was known as like the superwoman
because she would always run her test
really fast and so she had a really high
like that unrealistic productivity
compared to other chemists so other
cameras was complete about a thousand
five hundred tests and she would
complete like six thousand who are you
all doing a lot of time so it's like
unreal it so no one was checking her
work yeah apparently no one was reading
oh my [ __ ] god so she was just saying
path got my work done
pretty much and she also lied on her
resume oh saying that she graduated
magna [ __ ] laude which I'm told I she
graduated from data that they don't even
have that distinction so she also cool
she had also sworn under oath that she
had a master's degree but she didn't Wow
come on message I mean that's why
sometimes I'm like you don't really need
a degree because you nobody nobody
checks yeah you go apply for a job I
don't know any job I really checks even
government jobs apparently they don't
check dude my sister's a veterinarian
and she's like I don't know what I got
my degree for didn't teach me [ __ ] about
how to do this job until I got there and
I'm doing it every day exactly dude
that's how scary is the world that we
live in so I could just say I'm a
dentist I got my degree all meld into
school I mean wasn't it at that teenager
that was actually practicing as a doctor
I knew the teenager he just started
walking into a hospital I do does it
Frank Abagnale right the yeah and I just
wanna points yeah flying planes and here
the doctor being a doctor being a lawyer
I mean everything yeah yeah so anyways
back to any though she uh so they
started investigating until like all of
her work she pled guilty back in 2013 to
27 criminal counts including perjury
tampering evidence obstructing justice
she also admitted to intentionally
making negative results into positive
Wow
and she admitted to dry labbing which is
only not to tell me what that is
that's why it's not like a sexual act or
end attention welcome to real all the
details of her okay okay you go ahead
tell me all right so yeah she admitted
to dry labbing which is what that means
is testing only a few samples but
reporting the same result for the rest
of that dry laughing oh [ __ ] also what
was her motive for this I'll tell you
this again so she also admitted to
forging coworkers initials and mixing
drug samples so ultimate ajam ass [ __ ]
ultimately she was a bartender mixing
[ __ ] all day in there he also pled
guilty to one messy desk very messages
it's like you know like some of these
are really weird
yeah so she was sentenced to three to
five years she got out of prison back in
2007 and your motive was to increase
reputation and produce to be so she
wanted to be the best but your number
one chronic manipulating everything so
she could be the number one math tech
mental you get notice to get caught
exactly and that's what happened she
could actually have had her job and lay
on the DL you know and done it fine
yeah that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard well what's the real
aftermath of this if she messed with or
she tampered with 19,000 cases there are
19,000 criminals that are not out I
should have been in or was our induction
that should have been out the actual
number okay so the judge had ordered the
district attorneys to produce a list of
all the cases that they wanted to be
dismissed and so it turned out that
twenty 1587 convictions out of 24,000
worthlessness
so they took man there's more criminals
in the world because of her well perhaps
more innocent people - we don't know
yeah so let's yeah exactly so they're
saying that this has been the largest
dismissal in criminal cases in the
entire US and so many people that were
falsely imprisoned they lost their jobs
their homes they were even deported as a
result
of her work so at least for some people
they at least get to move on and have
that removed from the record because of
her but they're saying like if they most
of these people don't they didn't seem
like they would be innocent so that's
why her tests weren't really questioned
all that much this girl's so has you
thought you like this yeah yeah two's
you look like a criminal buddy got a
gallon oh okay thank you that's it you
know what the stupidest thing is she's
actually not number one because if I run
a marathon but just sneak up to the
finish line and run that little
reasoning one hey congratulate on I'm
first place but I didn't work for that
really I cheated she didn't care yeah I
didn't want to be known or she crossed
the finish line yeah and that's what she
wanted she wanted to CrossFit had the
ticker-tape like slightly you know
breathe doesn't sound very smart I know
it sounds like she has a very low IQ
that's so stupid man yeah with a sneaky
snake [ __ ] wish I did it
damn she better look guilty Zeldin oh
yes she does yep she's got that good
they're looking her fizzling that's our
flush you want to be called superwoman
no they called her that because she
probably had to keep up the reputation
like yeah I'm superwoman
that's impossible oh do you what do you
think it was like the day at work where
they're like um hey Susan like you know
we're just gonna be checking your work
today she's like oh [ __ ] oh oh yeah
great news I got a way more work to do
you know like like what she's like I'm
[ __ ] she's got to be like that if she
came out like that she's got no thing
always catches up to you man but you
know yeah what exactly that's why I'm
like she can't be that smart like how
can you not think long-term consequences
like that it's not even not long-term
it's like it could be next month they
check your work where she [ __ ] up is
uh if the average is a thousand cases
just do 1,200 mm-hmm why are you doing
6,000
yeah and raising what I'm saying she's
like getting noticed that way she could
have just like this is where you plead
insanity you're like you weren't in the
Y [ __ ] up it's like I thought I got it
all right
what I do I thought I got everything
right want to go show where they admit
that the other guy I did fudge 25,000
document I'd be like I thought I did it
right 100% right
should I just stop it yeah look and look
at these two samples it's like okay this
is this guilty or not guilty I'd like
yeah you don't say like I would just
hope with a crazy answer to try to get I
don't have it this why you want to be
number one like oh this is [ __ ]
stupid I really even know we don't even
know she told the truth or if the lawyer
told her to tell the truth she probably
hired a lawyer because you know when
they you know even people that are
innocent like they just a plea bargain
and stuff and they say things I'll be
your lawyer trying to play the game yeah
I'll be your lawyer
she died out in three years see that's
what's so funny buddy all these lives
were destroyed
she used to slap on the wrist that's
what's in the beginning video I think
she should be a personal slave for every
single person she put in the jail for
whatever time they were in jail for so
let's say I went to jail for three years
because she falsified my evidence eeeh
and then I own her for three years she
cooks for me cleans for me does whatever
the hell I want
see I think that's dope but a judge will
polish as cruel and unusual punishment
and I did that's where our Constitution
is completely Rexford cool and unusual
yeah it's cool and unusual I agree with
you I don't know and that's why we got
to change Constitution we do need you
you need the position in Jurmala
yeah I'm the law
loyal the lawmaker time official
lawmaker ironic that's a big job you
gotta thank God you guys wanna make her
of law so what is she up to now since
she got released from jail this is out
in the career great she owns a business
now
she's number one apparently and have
crazy result yeah huge sale is huge it's
just mash get hired after this rain you
know right well the only thing I know of
the aftermath is the fact that she just
hasn't spoken about it
that's it I don't just keeping quiet her
life is since last year that she's lips
talker I hope you're doing real good
inspection thing and she's like this
house now no water damage here check it
off let's go to the next house like she
lied I want her in charge Alaska check
her yeah she's like looking at this [ __ ]
down man what if she becomes a safety
inspector iron safety exactly so many
people diagnosis or a cop she's like I'm
not filming we're behind person we're
not we're gonna have to cancel monster
where they get some more perfect let's
just get a bus get a police bus start
throwing people in there yeah are those
real by the way police quarters uh four
tickets yet for tickets yeah I had a cop
for a teacher he was like a retired
sheriff and he says no but I'm like yeah
you did wait but there's a difference
between Highway Patrol and cop key why
should you purchase an abuser I love it
end of the month the oh my things they
start poppin off the end of the month
tell the Highway Patrol so coincidental
I think they have a quota what I heard
was that it's kind of like a reflection
of are you doing any work because if
you're not arresting people or if you're
not giving away tickets that what are
you doing so there's no real quota
people are always committed crime but if
you live in [ __ ] Mayberry dude you're
a man
where's life bury her you know it's like
one of these men like like nice little
communities where nothing bad happens
like a dozen people sounds like it could
be the hood what was really my friend
he's a sheriff
and he says that he doesn't really like
writing tickets or giving those out and
all that stuff he says that his focus is
arrest because once you arrest a lot of
people that you know have warrants and
all that stuff then he gets to upgrade
and do all the different stuff it's
worth more I guess the promotions then
sitting around and giving tickets all
day but when you're a Highway Patrol and
that's all you do it's probably
different yeah but how would you like to
be good at that job because then I don't
think they're going to move you on if
you're getting like the most speeding
tickets if you like doing great why
would they move you up to detectives but
I'm not sure about this level I'm just
making up
but I'm like why would they move you up
they don't move you up you just need to
keep your job what about them I'm
thinking about the money
no I want to say I'm cop shows they
always wanna make detective there's
other stuff but not have a video that's
like come on I gotta make detective come
on like I think I'm better than you
because I'm basing mine off super
troopers and your fake insurance off of
a cop chef like Chicago no you don't
even get it
there is super dreamers they'll move up
to Detective a new quota so they can
save their department he wanted to do
like a specialized game unit where he
doesn't go in those patrol cars anymore
and it's just for like when there's
calls for gang activity oh that's nice
and then the schedule seems pretty cool
because you know she only works like
nights and three days out of the week
that's so scary though you could deal
with games all the time he says that's
what he does now and like what is it
Englewood or whatever yeah you said
there's a lot of politics and you just
get to know people and talk to them hey
guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it I know you did
so make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up and to watch more videos you
can watch them up with here
[Music]